استولى مقاتلو الجيش السوري الحر على
الكثير من الاسلحه خلال معركتهم ضد القوات
الحكوميه فهذا هو اكبر مدفع رايناه حتى
الان بين ايديهم وهذه قذيفه هاون تركب على
عربات عملاقه من عيار 120
مليم وهنا ناقل جنود مدرعه وبعض المدافع
المضاده للطائرات التي تحمل على شاحنات
صغيره خزنا اسقاط تم اسقاط طائره كامله
باذن الله طبعا يعني
قريب كثير وبعد لحظات سمعنا صوت مروحيه
تحلق فوق
المنطقه نحن ننظر حاليا الى طائره
هليكوبتر تحلق فوق البلده ونسمع اطلاق نار
وهذا ما يخشاه المقاتلون فمعظم قتلى الجيش
الحر الذين مررنا عنهم سقطوا بنيران هذه
المروحيات ويبدو انها قدمت من مدينه حلب
المحاصره والتي تقع على بعد سته اميال من
بلده اندان التي يسيطر عليها الجيش
الحر
يقول المتمردون السوريون انهم يقاتلون من
اجل التخلص من نظام الاسد وانهم نجحوا في
طرد القوات النظاميه من هذه البلده ولكن
الثمن كان غاليا فالبلد اصبحت منطقه اشباح
ولم يتبقى فيها احد باستثناء
المقاتلين هذا هو سبب ترك البلده فمنذ
يومين كان هناك ثلاثه اشخاص اكراد من خار
المدينه يستقلون هذه العربه الصغيره وايضا
هذه الشاحنه وقد استهدفوا من قبل حاجز
عسكري بالامكان رؤيته من هنا ولا زالت
روائح الجثث تنبعث حتى
الان المقاتلون يقولون ان هناك قاعده
للجيش السوري في المنطقه المقابله لنا ولا
تبعد سوى اميال قليله حيث كان الجنود هناك
يطلقون النار تجاهنا وصوت الرصاص يدوي فوق
رؤوسنا وفي هذا البيت الذي يعود لاحد
الاثرياء تقيم فرقه من المقاتلين بشكل
مؤقت ولقد عرضوا لنا بعض الاسلحه التي
استولوا عليها من القوات
النظاميه مشان
جدران مشان المباني
مشان وبسبب قله الدعم الخارج الذي يحصل
عليه المقاتلون فان كل رصاصه هي كنز حقيقي
بالنسبه
لهم